and welcome to hannity tonight democrats
they are in a state of panic their
far-left ideology is unpopular their
policies are a disaster their president
well most americans agree is mentally
unfit their vice president is
incompetent their poll numbers are worse
than ever and now their precious twitter
is under new ownership now the days of
arbitrarily banning or censoring speech
appears to be over free speech according
to elon musk is coming to twitter and
high in their ivory tower america's ever
so fragile left liberals they can't seem
to handle it emotionally it's getting
funny now notorious fraud elizabeth
warren called a quote dangerous for our
democracy and then threatened to take
elon musk's wealth by force let's just
take all his money we'll steal it now
socialist uh senator ed markey he was
openly worried about elon's dangerous
influence over the social media platform
the congenital liar adam schiff tweeted
quote i am concerned elon's personal
views the views will stop the fight
against disinformation on social media
hit the biggest liar in the country now
make no mistake no one in america has
pushed more disinformation than him now
he frequently claimed that there was
direct and ample evidence of russia
collusion that turned out to be a lie
and a hoax and a conspiracy
theory that he sold to america for years
now to this day adam schiff he continues
to cast doubts on the legitimacy of the
2016 election adam schiff isn't worried
that americans will be exposed to
disinformation no he's worried they'll
actually be exposed to something called
the truth something he's not really
familiar with like for example hunter
biden's very real laptop from hell now
in 2020 twitter completely censored new
york post and their bombshell report on
the laptop just weeks before the
presidential election they even banned
private messages linking to the story
and they locked twitter accounts of
america's oldest daily newspaper at the
time twitter claimed the post violated
their hacked materials policy but the
materials were not hacked there was no
evidence that the material was hacked in
any way shape manner or form now in
reality twitter blocked the report for
one reason and one reason only to
protect joe biden period what did i call
it that's right the candidate protection
program
now yesterday twitter's new owner
tweeted quote suspending the twitter
account of a major news organization for
publishing a truthful story was
obviously incredibly inappropriate and
now something else inappropriate appears
to be going on at twitter shortly after
elon's successful bid to buy the social
media giant well conservatives on the
platform all of a sudden out of nowhere
enjoyed a massive bump in followers and
interactions for example in just two
days donald trump jr oh magically he got
200 000 new followers that it's uh
roughly 2 000
increase daily wow it's almost as if
twitter employees lifted a broad
anti-conservative anti-trump shadow ban
which we all knew was taking place
anyway in an effort to cover their
tracks before the new boss takes over
now twitter claims that there's nothing
nefarious a play here but they've said
that all before now we know the current
executives at twitter are far left
political hacks
we have witnessed their dishonest their
deeply biased gatekeeping over and over
again but hopefully that's going to
change and stories about the biden
families very real corruption might even
be allowed to trend at some times now
like this very interesting development
according to newly uncovered emails
hunter biden trashed bill clinton and
everyone around him he referred to
clinton as an a-hole who looks like adam
schiff
and he also referred to clinton aids as
petty greedy venal and low rent for
getting paid by the clinton foundation
and apparently according to hunter the
only classy way to make money is to sell
out your father's office to let's see
the communist chinese and russian and
russian oligarchs ukraine avoid paying
taxes and then spend millions on crack
cocaine hookers and low mileage uh
leases on exotic cars all while saving
10 percent for the big guy that's right
president joey we'll have a lot more on
my monologue in just a minute but first
here now with reaction is louisiana
senator john kennedy
senator i don't know
i do four hours on air a day and from
what i understood is all these
conservatives like president trump they
were canceled on platforms like twitter
and instagram and facebook uh etc uh we
know shadow banning has taken place on
many of these platforms and now all of a
sudden the left is fearful
that information might not be flowing
freely it sounds like what they really
fear is the free flow of information
your thoughts
well sean the uh the twitter
executives are
they're very upset this week i think i
think mr musk made a couple of them cry
i'm sure that uh more than a couple have
gone out to
and already bought an emotional support
pony
but here's what's going on twit twitter
is run
by wokers wokers represent the crank
wing of the democratic party
uh wokers as i've said before easy to
recognize most of them eat food only fit
for rabbits they almost always enter a
swimming pool by the stairs
they also don't believe in free speech
i do
which means i respect the right of the
wokers to have their opinion
but i have an opinion and here's mine
experience shows
that the wokers who run twitter
are intolerant
uh they're intemperate
uh they're foolish um
they're unthoughtful
experience shows that the woker
executives
who run twitter
um
they they don't respect any opinion but
their own
and they censor all others
they're also not normal americans they
believe for example that that kids
should be able to change
their gender at recess they believe that
cops are more of a problem than
criminals
they believe that government employees
in florida have a constitutional right
to talk to five-year-olds about
sexuality now again that's all okay this
is american you can believe what you
want but they can't and shouldn't
censor those on twitter
who disagree with them
mr musk has bought it and here's what i
think he should do i think he should
call in
all the woke
twitter executives and say folks we're
going to start respecting free speech
i promise you at least one will say mr
musk we can't do that and i won't do
that
that's the one mr musk should fire
and i actually take it a step further i
i i think you should clean out the whole
organization i don't know if you heard
about the one lawyer
uh apparently broke down crying over the
fact that elon musk took over elon musk
said something that really struck me
senator he said that for all my critics
out there i hope you stay on twitter so
you can learn what free speech is all
about
basically inviting them to criticize him
now what's amazing is you you have all
of these
left-wing news people and all these
left-wing politicians saying well hang
on a candidate or a politician might get
banned or throttled back and i'm
thinking
do you not know what has been happening
over the last number of years how do how
do they
um
bifurcate their brains into thinking
it's okay to do it to a conservative but
only the threat of it happening to them
finally wakes them up to the importance
of freedom of speech
well the irony is rich
look
what musk is proposing is is nothing
extraordinary
he just believes in free speech now what
does free speech means
it means that you're not free unless you
have the right to express yourself it
means you're not free unless you can say
what you think
he is not telling the wokers that they
can't express their opinion
on twitter
what he is saying to the wokers the ones
who run twitter you can't censor points
of view that you disagree with
that's the way america works that has
not been the way
that twitter has worked
and i think it's very refreshing
let me ask you
should there be obviously you got to
have a limit no nobody should be able to
make a physical threat against somebody
of course no hate speech you can't make
a physical threat that's illegal
anyway
the question is what do you do if you
really want to have a freedom of speech
platform i mean any reasonable person
with a conscience and a soul the poor is
real racism and deplores
real anti-semitism
do you let those people say what they
want and assume that the free market
will just kind of weed them out and
people won't pay attention to them or
should there be some standards that's
that gets a little more complicated well
you shouldn't allow hate speech
um but you've got to trust americans
you've got to trust people
to be able to think for themselves i
i'll give you an example uh the wokers
probably the woker executives are on
twitter they believe that all white
people are racist
now
i think they want to
as silly as that is they should be able
to say that on their own platform but
people who disagree with them should be
able to disagree
and say no that in and of itself is a
higher form of racism and here's why
that's called the free exchange of ideas
and that has not been the case on
twitter and everybody knows it including
the woker executives who run it the
thing that's why they're so upset
and i don't i hope i don't think mr musk
is going to back down my advice to my
my friends at twitter who are running
the place is look there's a new sheriff
in town go fill out her feelings report
but things are going to be different
don't send out a hurtful i don't know
why every time you say the word woker it
just cracks me up makes me laugh uh but
they're really out there uh senator
we're watching your race but you're so
popular in louisiana i don't think there
are even many workers that live in
louisiana
we have some we have some walkers but
but look they're entitled to their
opinion
um
how can i put this
i have the i have the right to remain
silent i just don't have the ability
i say what i think and i have that right
as an american and if you disagree with
me
uh you're entitled to disagree with me
that's what makes america work and
that's what twitter has been missing
i have the right but i choose not to uh
i have the right to remain silent but i
i don't have the ability
i don't have that ability either senator
kennedy
we we love having john thank you for
being with us all right now it's no
secret that biden's poll numbers are
historically bad quinnipiac had him at
33 percent approval rating even in deep
blue states like oregon new mexico biden
is underwater and today four new polls
have biden down by double digits
nationwide including a 17-point deficit
in rasmussen a 13-point deficit in
politico and according to gallup
record-setting inflation is contributing
to these numbers now still joe is not
attempting to pump an additional 1.6
trillion dollars into the economy in
order to pay off all student loans in
other words if biden gets his way his
new plan forget about the 40-year high
of inflation record high gas prices
everything costing more in every store
you go to every american family will now
be forced to shoulder a 13 000 burden
now it doesn't seem to matter if you
didn't even go to college or if or if
you already paid off your loans i paid
off my loan 58 dollars and five cents it
took me 10 years to pay it off i paid
every penny maybe you worked your way
through college like i was working my
way through college at the time to
mitigate the cost everyone will have to
pay so biden can appease his radical new
green deal socialist base by the way
what does this have to do with anything
green it doesn't the whole green new
deal
is only about higher energy prices which
makes america less competitive and it's
resulted in the highest gas prices we've
ever had a 41-year high in inflation and
everything we buy in every store costing
more how is that working out hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else